the term queen of the day is basically
in the rat or a snitch yeah yeah same
thing yeah well you never heard that one
before yeah it's well it's not a
gangster so that's you good observation
yes so if you're in the street we all
know what it there's no excuse for it
you made it an appointment to meet the
government you Queen in a day you're a
rat snitch whatever informant so guys
like and that's the bank he's trying to
sell something to guys like you that
don't know what all this is
okay so gangsters know what it is and
street guys criminals and so you know
there is no change you know the problem
is with most kids younger kids when they
get well in the street they don't
understand informants they don't
understand what the staying with ten
kids they'll think that somebody's never
you know he's a stand-up guy by the
street mentality stand-up guy and he's
not going to talk to the police but then
there's three cause of the guys are
going into the police and they're given
information and people don't know it and
as yeah because you yeah I mean it seems
like more like the number one rule when
it comes to any kind of any kind of
street business or or anything the
number one rule is you never snitch you
never flip right because that's that's
your dignity that's that's everything
right that's what you're judged on is
the number one thing you're just judged
on no one if you want to if you want to
make it in organized crime or if you
want to be in the mob if you flip you're
dead you're a dead man right yeah I mean
listen by simple ways the way you're
saying it the belief on the street is
that but that's just my perspective yeah
I mean listen that's the problem is it's
most kids perspective okay and they
don't understand the street so when
they're on the street and your partner's
what a guy and he's stealing half the
money or he's not giving you the fish
yeah so there's where it starts right he
starts taking a little extra and he
doesn't tell you in your part as well so
that's one problem okay who goes on a
street greed
second problem is guy starts stealing
each other's girlfriends and woman when
they're not around so that's the second
part there's a second part no loyalty
third part is when something dangerous
goes on and it's gonna be you gonna get
shot or he's gonna get shot you're gonna
run and let him get shot mm-hmm
fourth parties guys are gonna soon as
they run into a little problem with a
their girlfriend a boyfriend or mother
or fall and may be involved with them
they're gonna sell you out to protect
them so there is no real code of honor
like everybody thinks it's garbage and
you know the the the the tell-tale for
everything reading I don't care what
religion you all read the Koran read the
Bible read whatever if you're Buddhist
yeah money is evil right and this is
what the problem is money is controlling
the streets and as long as money
controls the streets the loyalty isn't
to your friend at the apartment or to
the organization it's to the dollar bill
and instead of following a path where
you can make a dollar bill the right way
everybody's trying to take a shortcut
and at the same time they're selling
each other out left and right and it's
not something I am talking about and
somebody says oh he's full of [ __ ] just
go look at history go follow religion
and watch all the murders that go on
through history yeah follow the wars
follow the Roman Empire and see what
everything's about watch a movie like
the Braveheart and see what it's about
being taxed and taking money from the
poor and then it's also about watch
somebody who has no money the inner-city
kids and when they get jammed up or
locked up watch how many years they get
compared to some rich kid that's got the
money like God he did to deceive and law
uniform and and weasels way out and pay
his way so you know it's not structured
fairly and and the world's not fair so
if you want to level the ground in a
fair way go to work the right way and
you don't have to worry about all those
things they just spoke about right right
and you take the right path because easy
to take the wrong path I mean listen I
took the wrong path my whole life I've
been you know stabbed up I've been shot
I've been batted I spent 18 years in
prisons I spent probably a good last ten
years of my life in in prisons were
without a yard I didn't see the yard I
was locked up 23 did I was a day at 24 I
showered three four days a week at best
and I spent probably seven years in
solitary confinement so when people say
you know [ __ ] you they don't want to
hear what you got to say listen I can't
make
buddy listen but I hope the people that
us offering a little bit or people have
jammed up with cases or people thinking
about going that way
take a second a second stance and say
you know I don't want to end up in these
prisons I don't want to be shot in the
head because you know I can maneuver
guys all over that's what I did for a
living I get friendly with you and after
I get friendly what you you think you're
involved what else and I shoot you now
so it's done just as easy as that and if
I know you had three hundred thousand
dollars in your house
well there's your life was worth to me
three hundred thousand your life's
finished so if you think there's a code
between guys and this guy's a lot more
vicious than I am so that's the reality
of the street holy [ __ ] it's not all my
stories you can go listen to podcast and
a podcast mob different mob true life
stories of different mobsters that are
talking when they go to jail and you
know their partners are rich and this
sitting in jail doing a time for another
guy that other guy that's out there
making money he's not helping his family
like he promised he's not doing anything
that he's not visiting him in prison
he's not stepping up and and doing
anything to help that guy get through a
time and and you're gonna hear these
stories they're gonna get guys sleeping
with guys wives and girlfriends those
stories right you know this is not
something that we don't know that we
don't you know think wow that's a big
surprise that happened to the guy and
every time I hear another guy telling
the story I would say well this is
exactly what we already know about you
know so I'm a guy that's been in prisons
and I've been international I have
friends in every country you name a
country and I'll tell you I could get
you in touch with somebody in that
country so you know I'm not just some
neighborhood gangster you know I was a
guy to travel I just came back from
traveling four countries I probably
since I've been home went to about 25-30
countries so I know the world I know
people everywhere every country so how
did you transition from New York and
Florida to going overseas what were you
doing overseas well you know since I'm a
kid you know I had friends at different
positions different mob families outside
of the Gambino when the Italian mafia so
I had organizations that were friends
with me with from the Columbia which I
was doing
in a cocaine business okay I have a
friend of mine Klaus that did business
with me since the early 90s and what
marijuana from California is from
Denmark so we're still good friends I
got friends that were the bosses and
families were ran things in the UK like
the Sabine 'is that I'm still friends
with so I can go through them all but my
obeying culture I'm Albanian we're a
very rough hands-on kind of culture very
violent oh yeah we come from you know a
suppressed country from the Ottoman days
till Turkey taking us over to communism
so you know I have friends in Albania
and guys that weren't business with me
for years that are back in that country
Italy so I can go on what country to
country Germany Switzerland so you know
these are all partners and friends of
mine over the years and that were in all
these countries so I those countries I
had hooks in those countries Canada I
have hooks in those countries and we did
business whether it was through money
whether those drugs whether it was
sports whether it was helping each other
if a friend of mine had a problem in the
UK which he did and somebody came to the
United States he asked me to go hurt him
from I did so we reached a lot further
than you know a typical you know a lot
of these mob guys never leave the
neighborhood Queens Brooklyn Staten
Island Manhattan wherever and I had the
ability because of some of the contacts
I have around the world to have the
ability to do what I want and I also did
it in a good way I have the ability to
go visit those countries and hang out
drink and have some fun
[Laughter]